okay I'm good Dawna can you give
me one clap please? here we go
one two three four five six seven eight nine ten. your nose
and get your mask off... if i'm talking in this
voice does it sound like i'm shouting? you're
filming all this right i want to make sure?
yes! let's get going. all right everybody?
as a journalist the thing you want to
do as a reporter and as a journalist
is to bear witness. when there's a big fire
burning we run towards it when a bomb goes off
we run towards it. oh god the smell. the sound to
cover it to find out what are the implications
for people that's what we do so i guess
you could say journalists are sort of drawn
to disruption. for two decades, the disruption in
the world has been continual it just never stopped.
at 15 minutes away from six there's the
view beautiful just a few clouds around the
area let's get into what's happening
through british columbia right now
welcome everybody to our brand new facilities
here at Global BC in Vancouver any preview
isn't complete until you've had a sneak
peek at what you're going to see on your
television sets on Monday so come on this way...
I saw that the Global network was wanting to
become national this really is a remarkable
studio people have put in long hours to make
sure that we can stream web video and that one of
the things that they agreed to do was to create a
national newscast. the countdown is underway Global
National is only hours away and I had just bounced
badly out of hosting Good Morning America and i
wanted to come home. one minute to the opening one
we wanted to disrupt the television landscape
a little bit in canada by putting national news
on the dinner hour and we wanted it to have
a very different voice. well we didn't want
to give people just here's a list of things that
happened today we wanted to put it in context we
wanted to tell people here's how it affects your
life. people are getting ready for work it's time
for kids to go back to school and it's time for
global national to take its first few baby steps...
when i look at the early stories the first six
episodes of global national news was softer
when global national first went on the air and
so that original plan that we spent five months
thinking about and executed for all of six
days uh was for an era that it turns out
didn't last very long. oh my god my goodness a
second plane now he's crashed into the other
tower of the world would have been packed
with people at this hour and we don't know
how many people were aboard the jet this
is no accident this is no bomb from inside
this is as you put it a terrorist
attack there's no two ways about it high
people are screaming down uh heading away from the
world trade center let's go let's go back up uh
having heard the second blast people
are running some of them running now
firefighters are in there for a major
fight the stairwells of course are how
people are going to be evacuated people
will be evacuated out of these buildings
and it was stunning i remember someone walking
into the control room looking up at the screen
and saying oh my god those are people jumping
from that building we go back to that picture
please uh in the control room it's difficult to
know let's take it full frame if we can please
but it looks as if that second tower has either
had sections of it fall off or has just collapsed
that stays with you just oh my goodness what is
going on i was sitting on the anchor desk looking
at the city i'd lived in not even a month
ago and now i was looking at towers where i
knew some of my friends worked. but 9/11 happened
i was in the tel Aviv bureau of NBC news
and like everybody in the rest of the
world we were just glued to our televisions
an unbelievable scene in new york city you
can see the whole lower part of manhattan at
this hour engulfed in smoke and flames as the
second section of the world trade center has
apparently collapsed in flames. so when we got
to liberty state park on the jersey shoreline
it was it was a view you were basically
looking at the city of new york burning
the odor like the smell of of smoke is one
thing right a campfire smoke that's one thing
but the smell of um things that aren't normally
on fire on fire uh is something you don't forget
where are you what happened what the building
collapsed part of the building collapsed it was
hard we went on for 16 hours and we did we didn't
buckle but after those 16 hours uh i drove home
and it was a beautiful sunny blue sky day in
vancouver with the north shore mountains and uh
i pulled over the side and i cried uncontrollably
for about 30 minutes. Elizabeth Rivas knows the
chances are slim but clings to hope her husband
might still be found alive but he can be injured
and maybe they don't have his name we started
bumping into people that were panicked at
locations throughout new york the lineup stretched
sometimes around the block with people looking for
any news of their loved ones this woman was
trying to find out about her brother he's
light skinned with freckles and they would walk
right up to the cameras and just hold it in front
just desperate and and overcome with with i guess
it was the grief um you know i've never seen that
kind of grief in that volume um before. this
is what it's like when a war is in your home
i think after that it almost said
well almost anything's possible
it just changed the you know the whole
potential for what could happen next
i think that pre-911 uh life felt safer uh i think
journalism seems slower paced when global national
went on the air that's kind of the experience
that i expected it would be but then 9/11 happened
and then afghanistan war happened
and then iraq happened and then
it was just one major crisis after another on
top of each other we couldn't catch our breath.
tonight war is inevitable evacuations of
westerners underway in iraq president bush
preparing to issue saddam hussein the final
ultimatum a third of our naval warship fleet
has been committed along with planes and
some special forces from the east coast
three frigates a supply ship and a
destroyer equipped with sea king helicopters
are heading to the persian
gulf and the mediterranean
it's calmed down a little but uh still hairy
still a little nerve-wracking for a lot
of the people here we had another several
missiles come in today just watching those
very powerful bombs um take out major
installations and and the palaces in
in baghdad fighter jets bombing
the capital Kabul and other cities, an apartment block was hit...
the story that i will never forget from
afghanistan is march 8 2008. we went out to
kandahar to see how women in 2008 in afghanistan
were acknowledging international women's day
and we went to this compound where you're
behind a closed door and we sort of waited
there was a first event happening just wait here
we're going to have speakers people will come
and you're wondering who will come
there was just women coming out
from all over the place and the thing that stood
out for me from that is the bravery first of all
that there would have been to leave their home and
come celebrate women when women are absolutely not
celebrated by so many in that country at least
not by the taliban regime and then there was
this woman who did an interview with us so she's
not only brave enough to come out she was brave
enough to show her face and talk to us about
what life was like to be a woman in afghanistan
in that time and she talked about how women
were treated like dogs that was her word were
but not like a dog like a pet like a dog
that you kick a dog that you beat when it's
down and you hurt again and you treat just
like this animal living in your home and so
for me i can see her face i can hear the cadence
in her voice and every international women's
day since hasn't passed without me thinking
about her and wondering after she went home
what happened to her. almost in a daze he tells
global national the same thing twice robin the
whole point of operation was tarik is to win over
the afghan people the canadian addition to maxim
30 000 people cross here every day and most
of them get by with a wave people saw it and
they knew that they knew we were at war but they
didn't really process that until we started seeing
those absolutely heart-wrenching
repatriation ceremonies that were
just i remember every every single
one i ever watched and and they were
a feeling we hadn't experienced as as a
nation before ramp ceremonies like the one
that happened here today are unfortunately
becoming part of our national experience
the vehicle trooper mark wilson was in struck a
hidden mine or bomb on saturday he was helping to
build a road in the dangerous pathway district in
our five days of broadcasting from afghanistan his
was one of three deaths all members of the
royal canadian dragoons all killed helping
to construct that road. while i was in afghanistan
i had the absolute honor of covering the story of
when some families came to visit and there was a
memorial and then they spent some time at the um
at the wall where all the pictures are. a
compulsion to see and stand in the last
place their loved ones did brought 17 canadians to
kandahar airfields tim goddard's daughter nicola
was the first canadian female combat soldier
to die in battle. nicola goddard's dad was there
my wife sally decided that she didn't want to
come she feels at peace with things as they are
i felt the need to come it was it was just a
lovely service and i remember standing in the
background and my sunglasses on because i'm just
bawling so so the children's i had one and uh
my uh my wife got it for me and nicola always used
to laugh about me wearing it and so i thought it
was appropriate to wear it today i think this is
the other part that people don't realize is that
we're so stoic on camera but a lot of times
we we wear a lot of the stories that we cover
to really understand afghanistan
you've got to get outside the wire
we were out on patrol in a village a couple
times with Matt Dawe did you say you're just for
audio your name and uh rank sure captain
Matt Dawe that's pretty good good not bad
sorry man i'm just gonna throw myself out
here so how did you guys sleep last night
all right matt was 27 at
that time when he and i met
and uh right away right away you could see
the leadership skills there our platoon
right now is providing security on the uh on the
flanks for these guys as they're going through
how did i find out matt was killed so it
had been about two weeks since i last saw
matt uh and i was uh sitting at home and i
turned on global nationals a day off for me
and then i saw the story and it hits you so hard
that young man was quite young probably didn't
remember his dad but boy would i tell him lucas
how are you bud good you good first of
all just uh absolute pleasure meeting you
really is yeah thank you i can talk a little bit
about your dad and my time with him if you're okay
with that yeah that sounds good what really
uh impressed me about him was that he sort of
embodied core canadian values small town
canadian values whatever you want to say
he was just a really nice decent guy he's the kind
of canadian you wanted representing this country
in those villages in afghanistan he exemplified
everything that was uh true and right about our
nation we're not a perfect country but we're a
good country we're a caring country filled with
really caring people i'm just curious what kind
of things you think you'd like to do in the future
i was i like police officers like i'm kind of
looking to something like that because i want
to help out in the community and especially with
things going on right now i kind of want to fix
all that and just kind of fix everything yeah and
i want to be involved like in the community and
kind of just get out and just experience things
good for you all your family's got such an amazing
record and history of public service
uh that doesn't surprise me thank you
just wanna if you roll i'll
just get a question the uh
this place is not very big when i
was in afghanistan one of the things
that i found myself hoping was that maybe
someday when my kids were 18 or something
i could go back there with them and the things
would have improved enough for that maybe we'd
fly into that kandahar airport the civilian
side fast forward to today that's not happening
for some reason when i look
back i think of my kids and go
that's too bad that was what i was hoping
for and i guess it was way too optimistic
how has it come to this this is just horrific
they have nothing to lose these people are
human shields and they're just moving with
all their heart all their might
like it's their last night here
tonight on global national engulfed in flames
forest fires whipped by high winds devour a huge
chunk of an alberta town look
at this a whole bunch of fire
highway 88 right here and people are looking
to get out good evening we're coming to you
tonight from athabasca alberta where one
of the three evacuation centers has been
set up for the thousands of residents forced
to flee slave lake other than get out of here
i think the biggest disruption in our
lives it's happening in slow motion
but the biggest disruption in
our lives is climate change
these are the smoldering remains of slave lake
burnt buildings charred vehicles a ghost of a town
seven thousand once called home this is probably
the worst curveball nature has ever thrown at us
and joining me now is shelley doucet
she's one of the people forced to
flee last night along with her young son
three and a half year old aiden shelly
give us a sense of how much
notice you got none none none
we've covered more storms than i can count
over the last 20 21 years extreme storms
you cover each one and no one feels qualified
to say this is climate change because it's
that cumulative body of evidence but
you look back at all the stories you
covered and all the people in every story
saying we've never seen anything like this
hurricanes snowstorms wind rain storms surges
in the village of dunrobin 53 homes
were hit by the ef-3 tornado on friday
and you think about those in combination and
you think yeah that's pretty compelling evidence
when you've covered flood after flood after
flood after forest fire after drought after
you know um pests um taking over farmers fields
because of um you know weather pattern changes
you just sort of shake your head and be like
are we back here again are we really telling
this story again haven't we learned anything
donna it is it is chaos really you hear the
emergency sirens going but i need to show you
it's not just on the border this is fort mcmurray
burning when reed did that one live hit where
we could see the flames behind him approaching
i think i looked a bit stunned on air because i
recognized what was happening i didn't want to
panic him but what i really wanted to say was reid
could you just stop talking and get out of there
but donna look at that like that
even in the past five minutes
has just flared up and uh to be honest i'm not
sure how long we'll be able to stay here but
it shows how quickly things are changing
it was a incredibly dramatic moment
i think in the time that i have
been a journalist the biggest
change has been again because of technology
because of the internet and because of cell phones
with cameras so they made everything much more
present they made uh made it possible for us to
see what was happening on the street immediately
global national from london here is Dawna Friesen
good evening tourists are fleeing
egypt by the thousands tonight
i remember thinking um when
that first began to happen
especially in the arab spring we relied so
much on citizen journalism and there was so
much hope and so much of a sense that this could
be transformational for these people who had been
oppressed and suppressed by their governments
well first of all just getting into egypt
as the arab spring was accelerating we realized
very quickly we cannot walk in like traditional
media anymore we can't bring that bulky eng
camera that we all carry that's quite large
it's much too dangerous for us to venture
outside today so we're stuck here in the hotel
with the rest of the foreign media watching
this incredible drama unfold looks like uh
the fighting has picked up again in fact it
hasn't really stopped it's a bit of a lull but
this is something i have never seen in my
life this is absolutely crazy just nuts us
being out there is just not a good idea right
now journalists western journalists have been
attacked assaulted uh our vehicle today was
surrounded by pro mubarak youth about 25 of
them we were basically held hostage in the
vehicle for about 25 minutes no no we are
filming for global television from canada we
are here to film uh canada canada yes global
so that weekend alone i remember going this
is absolutely crazy we're not carrying a bulky
camera around so in this case uh our photographer
barry acton and myself we walked into that protest
and that rally with two iphones and we filmed our
entire story relying on two phones i'm happy and i
want more i want more ragda and rauda are part
of the wired opposition they don't hesitate in
telling you who's responsible for this historical
moment young people on the facebook yeah
so you use facebook and yeah facebook and twitter
so there was a growing media ecosystem within the
middle east as well on top of um twitter
facebook and many other social media that
were just starting up so the entire
media ecosystem was just starting
to be disrupted and hosni mubarak and his
regime did not know how to deal with that
i remember being in sri lanka opposed the
tsunami boxing day tsunami and we were trying
to find a way to send our story back military
had set up blockades at almost every road
if they are caught helping journalists they could go to jail
but they agreed to try and show us something just
as long as we agree not to show their faces we
found this company to send our story back and we
called the satellite guy i don't know who it is we
called the person in charge of trying to help us
get the story back and he said you need to get to
the e6 satellite and we ended up doing six bounces
i believe like around the globe where the story
got sent you know to space and over here and then
above china and then down and over to america and
finally the story you know a couple minutes later
is in vancouver so that to me was like oh my gosh
wow look look what we can do and then next thing
you know a few years after that you are on your
phone taping yourself filming yourself talking
about an event and the story is there within
seconds or you're live streaming it. what cameras
in the hands of people have done of course
is take us to these immediate unfolding events
at one point he runs through a glass door
then back into the street towards officers
that's when several shots are fired
floyd was arrested after being accused
of using a counterfeit twenty dollar bill
an officer knelt on his neck
while he begged for mercy
one of the things that's happened with everybody
being witnesses and everybody having access to
video and being able to share it has been that
the definition of who gets to decide what news is
has broadened considerably
and so nothing really escapes
the eye of the witness anymore in this world
check his pulse check his right hand pulse! his
calls how has citizen journalism changed
everything i think you should just take a
look at the black lives matter movement if
those people weren't recording those things
we wouldn't have the evidence it's so important
because so many of those people didn't get their
stories told and they were just immediately shoved
aside and the stories were covered up frankly
you know technology is is usually what what leads
to um rapid change in society. wake up wake up!
it is the reason a white police officer in
minneapolis was convicted of murdering george
floyd it was because of a person holding
up their phone and taking a video of that
you are fake news alternative facts it's the
only true one that is telling the truth yes
and it's going to save us all..
i can hear you and i'm good we're good here all
right all right okay tonight on global national
standing by a building built by slaves
an african-american is sworn in as u.s
president i barack hussein obama do solemnly swear
our team of correspondents will bring it all to
you tonight but let's begin our coverage with
our washington bureau chief eric sorenson eric
kevin as a staged event the inauguration was
exceptional but as a moment in history it was
truly extraordinary i remember barack obama in
his campaign had used twitter and uh that was 2008
and i'd sort of heard about it i didn't think it
was all that important but for the inauguration
uh the obama team was tweeting out uh a lot of
their messaging for the first time and they were
tweeting out pictures of him behind the scenes
for the first time so i thought i'd better get on
twitter we integrated into the newscast we were
one of the first to do it because it seemed to
be a really useful tool and it used to be good to
interact with your viewers in in a substantial way
and then it stopped being good and then it started
to be harmful and then it started to be dangerous
and i think that's where we are now i have a
love-hate relationship with social media so i um
that it continues to this day from my perspective
my personal brand is sort of who i am as a person
isn't what's important for the job that i do
the importance from my perspective is really
delivering information to viewers and my ability
to do that is not you know increased if i have a
big social media profile i think it can be soul
destroying and i uh i just don't need that in
my life facebook was great initially because you
could connect with all your friends and twitter
was amazing as a journalist because you were
basically getting a live feed from witnesses
on the ground of of news events that doesn't make
it easy it particularly doesn't make it easy as a
woman because things are said about you that tend
to be said far less about your male colleagues
comments about your looks comments about who
people assume you might be in a relationship with
or trying to undermine people by saying well their
husband or their boyfriend or oh they're probably
sleeping with so and so it's shocking when you see
this and it's it's purely being done as a tactic
to try to discredit you it's vulgar but trending
often hurled at female television journalists
if they're spotted in the field this toronto
reporter could have swept it under the carpet
like women have been doing for centuries
i'm sick of this i get this every single day
do i feel as safe doing my job today as i used
to no i don't they'll say the worst things like
well they shouldn't be allowed in this country
or they put all this bigotry onto the internet
all these horrible comments and trying to police
those is not fun in my time i worried about
people being overseas that their danger would
be there i didn't dream they might be attacked
at rallies here not just verbally not just online
but perhaps physically and that's a scary thing
it was a bit of an eye-opener to me
just how dark parts of the internet
became and have become the fort hood killer
and the time square bomb suspect plotted their
attacks using the internet the russian spiring
employed internet cafes to avoid detection
increasingly criminals and extremists are
exploiting the internet to communicate
anywhere and everywhere. you look at how somebody
in a basement in Downsview can be radicalized
by the places of the internet that they can
go to we saw the results of that when there
was an attack on our parliament the gunman
somehow made it past security into center
block just as government and opposition mps
were holding their weekly caucus meetings
the gunman was shot dead in a
dramatic shootout in the hall of honor
he's been identified as michael zahaf bibow a
parliamentary guard was reportedly shot in the leg
shaken mps barricaded themselves inside
meeting rooms while others managed to evacuate
but we're seeing that now too and we're
seeing that primarily around white
supremacists and young white men who are being
radicalized in tribes and in societies and in
um ways that is massively disruptive
to the world that they actually inhabit
on this monday night from washington d.c just
hours left in a relentless campaign we are going
to win four more years from my news perspective
the presidency of donald trump was a non-stop
disruption team trump calls the media dishonest
the media called the trump team's assertions
falsehoods and trump aide kellyanne conway
explained it like this and you're saying it's a
falsehood and they're giving sean spicer our press
secretary gave alternative facts to that but the
point remains alternative alternative facts is
that emphasizing different facts or is it just
contradicting genuine facts it's the only true
one that is telling the truth yes and is going to
save us all i think the time where i realized how
pervasive misinformation is and how it often comes
from really common sources was actually attending
a trump campaign rally uh right at the tail end
of the 2020 campaign tell your governor open up
your state open up your school and we were in uh
north carolina we went to this rally and
every single trump supporter i interviewed
would come up with the same answers to my
questions are you worried at all about your
safety being here today packed together in a crowd
no not at all not at all will you wear a mask no
i think that there's a lot of other more pressing
issues than the pandemics and they were specific
statistics and specific facts that were all
false they were not true but they were rhymed
off as the answers to every single question i
asked about every issue ranging from joe biden
to the pandemic to the economy we are behind
him 100 percent the u.s is doing more than
your gov your canadian gov you know population and
they were all stats that they had heard on sources
like fox news or one america news or the more
fringy networks or on facebook coming from the
trump campaign and you realize what a fight we're
up against as journalists to tell the truth i was
you know i spent a lot of time covering
russia and that meant spending a lot of time
covering disinformation and you know these
really concerted multi-million dollar
campaigns to try and confuse us as canadians
and americans to try and you know sow division
just a short drive from the famous palaces of st
petersburg is an ordinary office
building that's become infamous
this for rent sign adorns the former home of the
now notorious russian troll factory which the u.s
accuses of meddling in its 2016 presidential
election and where vitale bisfala used to work
my job was to write 20 news articles a day full
of pro-kremlin propaganda he says and then share
the articles using fake online accounts i created
with photos taken from real profiles usually women
because they were considered more trustworthy
i remember like just being amazed at how
easy it all seemed it was it's sort of like they
would just find other people's photos online from
real profiles they would use those to make a fake
profile and then they would start using hashtags
and start promoting false information and then
that information would get retweeted not only
by other trolls but by literally millions of other
internet users you know give vladimir putin credit
for figuring out that he could disrupt uh so much
of western democratic society at such a low cost
disruption is creative rihanna taylor
ahmad aubrey disruption is destructive
disruption is opportunity people here
in the square who have a whole new
hope and they're so eager now and it's exhausting
nothing in decades has disrupted humanity and the
way we live our lives the way the pandemic has
even if you haven't become sick
your life life has been affected
because your life has been become
so limited and so restricted
i don't think we'll fully understand the
impact of it until a few years from now
pandemic was a confluence of so many story lines
there was tragedy with people dying there's
science with the vaccines there's the economic
factors here and then our personal lives were
affected i didn't see friends for months at least
three patients who had traveled from central china
have been hospitalized in both thailand
and japan do not travel outside canada
there are also new travel protocols that will
affect all overseas flights to canada and all
cruise ships that want to dock in canada
they are going from one 14-day quarantine
to another after two weeks on what some
called a floating prison i don't mind
this 14 days both myself and my wife we agree
that we should take this extra 14 days to be
virus free the first death in canada was at a bc
long-term care facility i want to start off by
letting you know that we unfortunately have had to
death here in british columbia i remember when our
public health officer dr bonnie henry had to
tell the media in her daily briefings that it
had happened and she broke down and i remember
we all sort of took a pause and i had a pit in
my stomach i actually felt really sick about it
because i thought this just isn't the first time
she's gonna have to deliver this bad news and it
went on and on every expert i'm talking about here
the more i'm learning about this suggests
that uh we're coming to a place where
you know working from the office for most
people is not going to be feasible anymore
hey i found you you sure did working
from home will either drive us batty
or get us to laugh at silly things
we used to have a section of the newsroom
where we all were together sitting close
right next to each other zenyu is that their
thing with the pandemic about 75 of the staff
in our building uh is working from home or just
remotely and so that meant a lot of empty space
i think the first wave was was scary because we
didn't know what was going on i mean we still
didn't really understand this virus and what
we were dealing with and i was terrified about
bringing that virus home to my wife and newborn
um by the third wave we knew what we were dealing
with in a sense but i had seen the hospital
i had not seen that hospital as overwhelmed
this toronto hospital is jam-packed
that alarm ringing through the halls is code blue
a man in his 40s just arrived with a suspected
case of covid19 and his heart stopped staff in
the emergency room inserted a ventilator tube
and saved his life while other patients are lined
up in the hallway just outside there were more
younger people in there they were getting sick
faster we were hearing stories of people dying
at home if you walk the halls of the icu you can
see up close the changing face of this pandemic
we were here in the first and second waves where
you largely saw elderly patients sitting in these
rooms but these days there are a lot more
people who are younger i've gone you know
sent to iraq when isis was there um been been in
hostile environments before but then you get back
on the plane and you go home and and there's a
bit of separation whereas obviously the pandemic
there really is no escape after 9 11 and and with
the threat of terrorism for years my grandmother
used to say um i i don't understand how people
can bring up kids it must be so hard with
all these threats and i would say grandma you grew
up in scotland during the blitz you had a bomb
shelter in your backyard we're okay the pandemic
is the first time where i've thought oh you know
what this is comparable probably to what you know
grandma went through it is a question of value
to quote oscar wilde do we know the price
of everything and the value of nothing when
this coveted crisis is over there are deeper
questions to tackle about the worth of heartfelt
hands-on work for now what we offer those doing
essential exhausting work is profound gratitude
tonight when you think back 20 years i mean
there's a whole lot of trauma that you remember
but i got to say what mostly comes the forefront
is the crazy time you have trying to do what you
do so we had so many great moments i remember
very early 2003 we thought like why don't we
put five people in a bus with chairs that like
won't go down so they can sleep and let's do 36
remote shows for an election across the country
going west to east like that that was nuts
that was crazy okay real fast but my favorite
story involves uh somebody who is behind the
camera right now kurt brownridge we were on a leer
jet and we found out from the from the pilot that
if you shotgun a beer on takeoff it goes down
with g-force so of course you had to try it
and i think kurt you cheated cheated a little bit
cheated a little bit but it was one of those uh
crazy wonderful moments that in the passage of
time with all that we've been through together
um those are the memories that stick the longest
say yeah yeah
oh can i tell this on camera jamie lost his
passport the night before we went to rusher he got
on some boys weekend or something with that you
were filming all this right i want to make sure
the time i almost missed the
prime minister's plane in japan
coming back because we were at the sake bar
trying different kinds of sake it was great
or then we got sent to iraq and realized he forgot
his computer cables he was driving around a market
in her bill trying to find another computer cable
i was able to change my clothes uh in the bathroom
of the car rental shove them into the garbage
box there um get into the car drive do my story
i was thrown up on and i still filed my story
when you look back on it you know the
exhilaration or adrenaline can take you a long way
and also just sort of reflecting on i don't
know how we were able to pull that off
it was the best um i loved it i've worked
with a lot of great guys i still believe
fundamentally you know after all the stories
i've done of horrible things happening and
people dying and you know terrible acts of
violence um perpetrated on other people i still
believe fundamentally in the goodness of humanity
hey my pleasure so great to meet you thank you so
much i often describe to my friends the hamster
wheel of news that we're constantly doing this
just trying to keep up with the volume which
seems even more like a fire hose these days than
it ever has been and so uh to take those moments
to look back and see what we've accomplished and
the stories we have delivered and the the
moments of of anguish in people's lives the
moments of agony but also the moments of real
joy over the years is is makes it all worthwhile
so
you